- C'est un combat à armes
inégales que mènent les pompiers
en Gironde, dans le sud-ouest
de la France. Le département
fait face à deux feux majeurs,
qui ont déjà ravagé
6800 hectares de forêt
et forcé l'évacuation
de plus de 10 000 résidents.
MARTIN GUESPEREAU
préfet délégué de la Gironde
- Le feu tourne, le feu
a fonctionné en escargot
à un moment, le feu est revenu
sur lui-même, le feu est parti
au sud, le feu est parti au
nord... Le feu nous a appris
à nous étonner.
- Pour faire face
à ces incendies sans précédent,
les pays d'Europe
se serrent les coudes.
ÉLISABETH BORNE
première ministre de la France
- Il y a des Canadair grecs
qui vont arriver aujourd'hui,
on a aussi des avions suédois
et puis on a aussi des moyens
terrestres qui vont
être mobilisés d'Allemagne,
de Pologne, d'Autriche,
de Roumanie.
- Ce pompier allemand fait
partie des renforts.
"On n'a pas hésité une seconde,
dit-il, on est arrivés dès qu'on
pu afin d'aider nos confrères."
Mais les autres pays d'Europe
ne sont pas en reste.
La Grèce, le Monténégro,
la Bulgarie, le Portugal
et l'Espagne combattent
eux aussi des feux de forêt.
"Cela brûle comme de l'essence,
dit ce bénévole bulgare,
c'est tellement sec, il n'a pas
plu depuis des semaines."
- Un nouveau plan national
d'adaptation au changement
climatique sera mis
en concertation à la rentrée.
- L'importante sécheresse,
jumelée à la vague de chaleur
sans précédent qui frappe
de plein fouet l'Europe
depuis le début de l'été,
pourrait finalement forcer
les gouvernements à faire
face à l'urgence climatique.
Ici Lise Villeneuve,
Radio-Canada, Montréa